good friend of mine season 3 of his IFC
original horror comedy series premieres
tonight at 10:00 p.m. Eastern Time
perfect time for a Halloween treat stand
against evils john c mckinley how are
you Johnny C never better
you said that every time I'm cursed I'm
fighting gravity I'm resolved
I'm reconciled you resolved in record
sound gravity everything's nice and
tight right now fantastic no yeah are
you painting quite the word picture for
our radio that's how I roll I know that
you only know one speed Johnny C
McKinley on I know that and you are on
the show right doesn't Suze have any fun
when you went to over the pond we did
what did you get to do we just hung out
no children you know one of the it's
amazing when you've got kids fry fly in
the front of the plane on the way over
so when you no one on the plane did you
take a left yeah yeah you did on the
left turn so you had about an 11 hour
vacation on the way over just the
greatest it's amazing how we missed our
kids the minute we left them and and
thought about them like every single
minute especially when it was just like
you know it'd be right about now we'd be
doing X Y & Z with them and all we have
to do is whatever the hell we want to do
it was great you got to get done glad we
had a good that's a good trip and it's
just you know London was by the way we
get tremendous job on that broadcast
let's not bury the lead Mendes job I
appreciate you saying that
thank you but I'll tell you what like I
would be walking down the streets in in
London and it's a very large city there
be like Jaguar fans and there is Eagle
fans it really was amazing it's
unbelievable and why did Jags there's
four games next year yes they already
announced what they haven't announced
what they are no I seem to be there
because the owner of the team shod Khan
has I think some business interests
there including potentially the purchase
of the stadium in which I just called
the game okay the soccer game - yes so -
Stan Kroenke which is why the Rams have
been there before it was the Eagles
first game ever on foreign soil they'd
never played one when you came back I
don't know when your flight back was if
it was in daylight it was I arrived in
daylight who you believe flying over
what is going to be the Rams facility it
is unbelievable
I know the the the sign the whatever
whoever puts the money into the
uninformed say say what we're talking
about this this need the signage on the
stadium the naming rights to the stadium
the if they will put their logo directly
on top or whatever anybody that flies
into Los Angeles will know exactly what
some piece of real estate it is it's
huge it's huge
I'm sorry about your Giants I'm sorry
about yeah so where do we go from here a
great question I don't know I don't know
because right now you can't even bench
Eli for the kid who just almost ran over
a cop truck that was a disaster last
year with myth was it that was a
disaster so well the problem with that
last year is number one was the coach
who did it and number two is the guy
where they turn to hmm it was a guy who
New York fans had a front-row seat for
his struggles as a jet quarterback that
was Brian had to tell you when we got
out of the gate beating a good Detroit
team who then goes on to beat New
England in Detroit with all the shiny
new toys and everybody healthy I thought
we were after off to a I thought we're
gonna be eight Nate mm-hmm I thought
that was a good indicator and really was
I wrong yeah I'm sorry to even just say
it that way pivot a little bit for you
over here rich pivot Johnny so now with
the playoff yes Chris and I were talking
this before you talking about this
before you yes do you give Central
Florida and I know your Michigan wanna
be on the bubble okay do you give
Central Florida after being undefeated
for a year yes let's say they went out
Michigan wins out which they're going to
mm-hmm
and so you have Alabama Clemson Notre
Dame and Michigan with one loss if
Michigan because LSU is gonna lose allow
me allow me well allow me to dupe the
central extrapolate extrapolate here as
somebody who has pounded the table for
an expanded playoff field I'm watching
and I agree with you to allow a team
like undefeated UCF in if and the
current construct of for four teams
Michigan beats Penn State this weekend
then Indiana then Rutgers and then
actually finally does
past the Ohio State University flight
understand they ran her with Urban Meyer
on the sidelines yes if that team then
goes to the Big Ten championship game
and vanquishes whichever team they get
placed in front of them only to be on
the outside looking in because an
undefeated UCF team gets in I would take
a pitchfork and a torch okay and storm
whatever gate I would actually have to
have even though they've been undefeated
for two years or and beat Auburn correct
yeah correct
Chris wouldn't you hear UCF yeah I mean
if if UCF no they have no chance against
any of these teams what I'm saying
they have no chance a lot of people
think that's the case but no way no way
I'm sorry I mean that's just the way
that this this you have to be in a power
five I'm sorry and if you expand the
playoffs to expand it to eight just damn
straight I do same here I bet I give an
automatic bid to whoever wins the
regular season of whichever cuz I'm
eliminating the conference championship
games I'm taking them straight out
because it just means absolutely nothing
so Conference regular season champion
just like old scan three outlaws like it
use 305 yes the five teams that can help
their divisions they get in or if you
want to keep keep the conference
championship games because for whatever
reason you love them then you make that
an automatic bid so you take a team you
take a team like say Northwestern that
scrappy has no shot of winning the Big
Ten championship without a Big Ten
championship game correct they have a
chance to win the Big Ten championship
and go on and be a Cinderella even
though they might get there you know not
great television I would take it because
you tell me this - wouldn't you Johnny C
McKinley if it does not conflict with
your stand against evil watching on IFC
at 10:00 p.m. Eastern times well struck
thank you sir
that wouldn't you sit there for all of
Christmas weekend and watch for 100
first-round playoff games in college
football 100% and to to juxtapose that
with I skip a lot of bowls I'm doing
that already though I know it's what I
mean so I'm already doing that right and
so now you're gonna bring me back I'm
gonna consume
content right if you have eight brain a
playoff I'm watching every single one of
those games would you not agree right
now Chris Brockman that the bowl season
right now is for two people who the
person who wants to watch their alma
mater play their bull and gamblers in
gamblers yes that's right of course and
gamblers
it's basically everyone who lost their
shirt during the college football season
a chance to win it back for the bowl and
figure this they know that they know
Boise State's got a chance in that
Yankee Bowl yep well they have no idea
about the Yankee bullpen sorters more
importantly is so it given Michigan wins
out and they're the four seed they play
Alabama Notre Dame plays Clemson the
line on the Michigan game will be around
eleven and a half or so against Alabama
yes 14 and a half against LSU this
weekend Johnny Dean LSU yes all the way
I would say she can give Alabama game
I'd love I'd love them to but see here
in Clemson they're going and give them
again and the Giants give them again
now it's hold on a second the whole idea
that the worst nightly giant blue I know
that I am never ascribed to the concept
that the worst NFL team would lose to
the best college team well no when you
and I were growing up when I was growing
up two years to do this you're young and
firm there was an all-star game where
the all-stars played I guess the champ
mmm did they play the end of the NFL
champ played against college all-stars
how'd that work out some not bad that's
what I'm saying the whole everyone's
like the oh and sixteen Browns would be
with lose to Alabama no they'd be like
21
I agree at least at least see but I
guess just to bring this whole full
circle John is that it is still college
football there is still supposedly an
academic reason why these kids are out
there at these institutions of higher
learning and so if we add an extra game
we're getting close to them playing a
professional football schedule we're
getting close to what right I mean you
put it in then playing 14 games 15 games
so that's a bit of a ruse though and so
I mean you're not you're not hurting
anybody this is these are the these this
is the best period of your life if
you're starting on Michigan right now
it's never gonna get any better than
this because you're not going to the NFL
you're not this is it mm-hmm why not
write it it's great this is it this is
the good old days let him ride it no no
you're gonna go to calligraphy class got
a day here is that what you did did you
have a calligraphy class no I wish
underwater basket-weaving Rather's book
years ago and he said he said that his
favorite class he ever took at Central
Texas or wherever he went right was
basket women come on yes dan Rather
dan Rather actually took basket well yes
it was best class he ever took and it
prepared him for one of the great
journalists of our life everything Sam
Houston State it prepared him for Wars
oh is that where he went Sam best is it
will you check the current curriculum at
Sam Houston State to see if it's now
like in its 60th year of basket-weaving
was there a 1 and a 2 basket-weaving
like I went to I was I couldn't find my
way so I went to Ohio Wesleyan his
freshman then I transferred to Syracuse
because I wanted to do what you're doing
okay and I'm really I went to new house
for a year and I only got to write copy
for upperclassmen and I was like if I'm
writing it I'm saying it and they're
like no you're not your sophomore and
I'm like okay well then I'm out of here
so I went to NYU to be a storyteller
undergrad and then I stayed and went to
NYU grad which was kind of theater boot
camp for three years yeah and was the
greatest experience of my life when you
were at Newhouse were there any anybody
that you were with that actually did go
into sports broadcasting or broadcasting
no isn't nobody know but you know brutal
it is no I mean that you pretty much
everybody's anomaly do you need a hug no
new houses turned out tons of people
come on no bombs Rico and Marv Albert
and dick Stockton right John McDonough
you you not me I didn't go to new house
you didn't oh you just went to Syracuse
for basket what you did I lost there at
Syracuse it was a grim year because the
the Carrier Dome was under construction
and the basketball arena was also my
Fieldhouse Fieldhouse was under repair
so all the basketball games were down in
the Meadowlands and all the football
games were down in the middle owned
Meadowlands are you a narc monk was a
senior Bob guy named Hurley Buffalo Bill
Hurley was the quarterback uh-huh
Meadowlands so did you go to any games
not one damn any money yes you're not go
down to Jersey with ones that's a long
way
those were good teams Sam yes exactly
all right let's take a break we'll come
back on a talk stand against evil with
you I want to talk about so many things
in your career you're one of the
greatest storytellers we have here on
the program and you want to do the news
in the next segment crisp let's say
you're we're gonna hang out with John
see McGill we allowed to heckle and
Jeckle the news this you may oh that's
what you're here for
see look where we are allowing you
because I know this is one of the last
things you've ever wanted to do is to be
part of a sports broadcast we're gonna
let you live out your new house dream
dude you're my guy again back giannis
came out here come here come here c'mere
c'mere we're gonna hug it out alright
this is great I do two men almost
lingered
I almost linger the only human okay so
John C McKinley is here on the Rich
Eisen show her back with he's uh the
news update and I want to hear a couple
of stories from your you told her Steven
Seagal's story in the television only
segment I wouldn't need to revisit that
a little bit all right that's coming up
next here on the Rich Eisen show
okay welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
again John C McKinley here hanging with
us stand against evil season 3 premieres
tonight on IFC at 10:00 p.m. Eastern
Time just in time for your Halloween
viewing you want to take a couple phone
calls here on the show before we get to
the news update 1% Mike one of your
college football chat and has inspired
some some chatter as you know rich I'm a
man of the people
okay Trey in Augusta Georgia you're on
the Rich Eisen show at John seem again
Lee before broccolis news update what's
up Trey hey rich I just heard you guys
talking about the 18 playoff yes and why
you think it's the best but my pitch is
actually for six teams how does that
work in six and the reason for that is
you get to five so number one number two
to five reason I don't like eight is
because out of conference rivalry games
become almost meaningless so you have
Clemson South Carolina you have Georgia
Georgia Tech Florida fourth state if I'm
the head coach to the team that's pretty
much slated to go to my conference
championship and I know that I'm gonna
get an automatic bid why would I play my
starters why would I try to win the game
and why would I do anything to risk my
players getting injured when I already
know I have a chance to get in on that
bit oh okay thanks Trey I appreciate the
unintended consequence there well I have
a I have a variable that could be
introduced to that okay
strength of schedule would sometimes I'm
spitballing the strength of schedule
would sometimes mitigate conference
champ so if it's a flop year for the ACC
could you spice in a 10% strength of
schedule component I think for an
at-large obviously for the at-large he's
pointing out that somebody yes nice turn
down the competition because it's out of
conference when they're already set up
to try and get in what they want to get
into the dance through their conference
championship game that they turned down
as he points out Clemson South Carolina
although wouldn't you think there's got
to be some sort of recruiting component
in there as well that you want to win
those games to win the hearts and minds
of the kids that they're right in your
front wheel just roll it back from not
an automatic conference
invitation that's true it could be the
five the five best teams plus three
at-large what are the five best teams
probably Conference champs but what if
it's a allows a year in like this year
what if it's a lousy year in the pac-12
boys it allows you here in the practice
so then maybe this is a year where there
there should be an out clause where
maybe conferences it's not automatic you
know right now the court again last
night the cfb playoff rankings come out
and they not only tell you who the top
four is they tell you who the first two
out is and then figure out what first
two out now Michigan and Georgia and so
Michigan would play Washington right now
in the row Amy Rose but Washington State
they play Washington State in the Rose
Bowl right now that's a good game
yeah Washington State is eight that's a
good game Michigan Washington State in
the Rose Bowl by the way turkey is
nineteen are you gonna take out know
what Sharon you just leave Clemson all
they could eat only if we wouldn't have
blown that game at Pitt we would be in
the top you'd be in the mixer well are
you going to beat Notre Dame at Notre
Dame right Mike he does they know he's
got no earthier you know it's had Notre
Dame yes no I'm a call right now we're
beating them because he wants to go to
the game oh is that well meeting them so
why would you know that we were talking
about Alabama doing aside from the
obvious what salable alabama doing
better than everybody else
is it just - two words Nick Saban um
what are the things there's one word to
us well know what they're also doing is
they Mariucci told me this and I think I
don't what I'm telling any tales out of
school that he spoke to Saban once upon
a time about coming back to the pros and
Saban's like well I if I go to the pros
I get one first round draft choice and
sort of the 31 other teams I stay here
in Alabama I can get five six
first-round draft choices why would I
want to you know that's that's what and
that's what they do better than anybody
else
I throw open the doors and they're like
who wants to come Alabama every
five-star recruit in the south I'm
straight they're right plus they get
they get a kid from Hawaii
it's right
and look at him who comes to the thing
is normally they have four or five
first-round picks on defense right and
then their offense just is just kind of
they're usually running bad at two Julio
Jones and Calvin Ridley yeah but they're
not normally the focal point when you
think about that Alabama team you always
think about defense yes and now they
have a Heisman trophy-winning
quarterback who doesn't even play in the
fourth quarter increasingly think about
from from Yeldon to the kid on new
orleans i also think about its that's
becoming tailback you Derrick Henry
Henry was a beast and what's happened to
him miss yeah I god this is fun chat
what happened to him this year in
Tennessee he was on the trading block
yesterday I was surprised he was not
moved because Dion Lewis fits that what
they're doing right now right it does
not fit what they're doing in Tennessee
right now right but that's what they do
better than anybody is they throw open
their doors and say who wants to come to
Alabama and everybody who knows anybody
who knows anything about talent they'll
still show up on the Alabama doorstep
and this kid to it it looks like this
week most likely yeah maybe
what will throw his first pass in the
fourth quarter this year he's not
attempted a pass he dominates and sits
they score 50 points a game I know it's
crazy even when they're not playing
Little Sisters of the Poor they still
score 50 points a game which is why I
think they lose they lose the LSU this
week they they still make the playoffs
and I think they should do it because
that means they avoid having to take on
Georgia and the SEC championship game
and still make it at any rate 844 204
rich number two down here on the show
before we get to the news update stand
against evil you shoot this where do you
shoot this down in Atlanta Georgia
Georgia and if people haven't seen it
it's Archie Bunker fighting witches
that's the high concept is that if that
floats your boat tonin if not all in the
witches yeah it's basically what it is
and so the interesting thing about what
we've done with Stan which is largely
about tone and what I mean is
so horror comedy horror being The
Exorcist on one end of the spectrum
which is really scary but you can't drop
a joke yes and then scooby-doo which is
funny but the threat is largely declawed
yes and somewhere in the middle of the
there is an American Werewolf in London
ash vs. Evil Dead and Stan and so it's a
really hard tone to maintain and we've
shepherded it quite meticulous like this
because the jokes can completely declaw
the threat or if the threats too great
it can cannibalize the jokes and so
somewhere in the middle there is where
Stan lives and we're just killing it
right now who's the funniest person he
ever worked with where they did crack
you up Rory Scovel on ground floor who's
that I'm sorry this is the funniest man
I've ever met
no kidding yeah he was in the last Amy
Schumer movie okay Rory's the funniest
guy I've ever met who is the funniest
person I wouldn't think that would be
the funniest like that Pacino ever heard
like crack you up or somebody I would
say Michael Douglas is coming here next
Friday underrated as a comedian because
of his timing and is bobby cannavale e
we walks on water for me all of us here
- Bobby Cannavale Bobby just crushes he
is I don't even think he's hit stride
yet and he's already crushed I don't
even think he's hit stride you did you
did
the Mamet play with we did a revival of
Glengarry Glen Ross and Broadway
together it was the greatest experience
of my life
incredible by far now you said earlier
that you were directed by Steven Seagal
on what film is this again on deadly
ground on deadly ground who is a little
bit crazier him or or Oliver Stone not
easy scale well Oliver is not that crazy
cuz he's so smart okay and he is in fact
the smartest guy in the room and so if
you can hew to his direction
Oliver is like a he's tantamount to a
Kentucky Kentucky Derby thoroughbred
with blinders on creatively and if you
can get in that vision that his blinders
are dictating the parameters of yes it's
nirvana if you want to operate outside
that creative vision it's a little slice
of hell and since I've done six movies
with Oliver some six I I've seen people
try to operate outside the Oliver's
vision for that particular piece
and so the Oliver and Stephen are two
different creatures obviously I'm that
that's understood so if you can get an
Oliver's creative vision for whatever
whether it's talk radio or platoon or
Wall Street or any given Sunday I could
go on but if you can get in that in that
sweet spot yes it's heaven how'd you get
in his radar originally I auditioned for
platoon and I got a tiny role and then
it went belly-up and it was not shot for
two years and then when it was
reconstituted two years later Oliver
offered me the fourth lead in the movie
Sarge O'Neill and we went off to the
Philippines revolution torn Philippines
and we shot platoon and it felt like you
were at work we did a three-week boot
camp in revolution torn Manila and then
we started shooting the film largely in
sequence which is unheard of so as
people's characters died they left and
so that started out eight times three is
twenty-four so it started out with 24 of
us and then by the end of it there's
three or four of us left and that that
diminishes how much the actors have to
act because everyone is gone you don't
have to act like they're gone they're
gone and so the lens suffers if you can
reduce the profundity of a lie in front
of the lens it it experiences that as
good acting and so the way Oliver set it
up the arc of people's stay in the
Philippines was dictated by when you
died in the script and because he shot
it almost chronologically as you died
you left and so the actors who were left
at the end of the film
those long faces and that and that fear
in people's eyes because there was a
threatened coup every Thursday because
the president did not have the military
in her back pocket a woman named Cory
Aquino there was always this threatening
buzz of a coup and there'd be no better
person in a coup than American actors to
take and and and use as whatever you
need jeez and so when someone calls
action and all of these things are
roaming around in one's skull the camera
sees all that and it and it cooks it
really pops in front of the lens
short dead man that sure did that movie
was it still to this day yeah he nailed
that one
Oliver did two tours and he tore that
film out of his sternum and remember
when we got home the big hit and what
people were experiences as a as a war
movie was Top Gun which was kind of a
Reagan error celebration of of
mechanical war and that's not what we
shot and so when we got home and Top Gun
was the big hit
you know we largely concluded that that
would wasted about four months of our
lives and then it turns out that Oliver
is gonna release it at Christmas and
nothing says Christmas like platoon
there's just nothing says Christmas like
full soon and so then it came out and
and it did it did what it did
oh my gosh that's unbelievable John
that's amazing in you know we it's it's
funny out we we mentioned off there I'll
mention here as well William Daniels the
actor who you've never worked with
correct he's I have not I certainly know
who he is he's 91 years of age he foiled
a robbery in his house and he was
credited as Boy Meets World actor and I
thought that that on behalf of those who
watched him in the graduate insane
elsewhere and 1776 it was an outrage for
him to be described as that Brock when
you knew him from a boy Boy Meets World
big boy means man go Feeny if you were
ever in a similar situation where you
fought off an intruder and it's John C
McKinley fought off an intruder right
how would you want to be from your ouvre
that's too easy
how would you want to be identified John
John Cena I would want to be Down
syndrome and special needs advocate
champion par excellence they're easiest
thing on the planet because that's what
you are when you're not what I care
about I know that I know that and it's
our 50th anniversary the Special
Olympics this year and I've been invited
to go give a keynote speech in
Washington DC on November 30th contester
a big gala dinner and that is thrilling
to me you were the man you were the man
at at John C McKinley on Twitter here on
the Rich Eisen show all right we're
gonna take a break we're going to
back we're gonna do your news segment
Chris there's big Saints injury news
correct how about them apples I have no
idea what this is all about am I gonna
am I gonna be particularly disturbed by
this I think it might affect things on
Sunday okay very very fascinating John C
McKinley here Chris Brockman's news
update your phone calls at eight four
four two oh four rich Jalen Ramsey our
number three that's how we're rolling
here on the show check out again stand
against evil season 3 premieres tonight
on a high FC just so you understand what
you've been here every single year I
mean you've been here through every year
of iteration of this program which by
the way turns four this weekend so
gradually she's tall you you sat out you
you once uh sat in for me with Susan I
substituted big shoes to fill
we tried our hardest so the reason why
is you know what I I deal with on a
daily basis so you heard me ask those
guys where Syracuse was playing Notre
Dame right yes that question and then
they both confidently said it had to be
at Notre Dame as Mike Dell tufa said
because the games at Notre Dame he
wanted to go right that's where you said
that apparently it's at Yankee Stadium
thanks for playing it's a home game for
Notre Dame but it's at Yankee Stadium
it's not in the state of Indiana it's a
mistake called New York it's a home get
Amparo call the Bronx you want to look
that up under Street train to it oh yeah
train partly it's called the shamrock
series yeah that would be Notre Dame
that'll be home game so that's what I do
is considering going to the Notre Dame
Navy game next fall in Dublin yeah
Ireland now that would be a hellbug
thing to go see we're given that some
thought right now wrong consideration
now this that's a home game as well
that's a real home that's a real home
gets a real love to do please go to
Ireland are you ready for the news
update like you read a please now that I
have just laid out the accuracy that
emanates from that part of the studio or
not see they're playing here okay stuff
about candy hit the drop please with the
news
sponsored by the 2019 Honda Ridgeline is
tailgate all-star features an available
truck bed audio system dual action
tailgate lockable in bed trunk to start
tailgating like you mean it
hits your Honda dealer right now and
check out the ridge line today
Christopher okay that Saints injury news
guys
Ian Rapoport saying Saints rookie pass
rusher Marcus Davenport Oh coming off
his best game against the Vikings two
sacks of Kirk Cousins last week
he's expected to miss about a month with
toe injury after that they'll see how it
responds he's in a walking boot right
now obviously terrible news with the
Rams coming into town let me tell you
what so the Rams get Dante Fowler Jr and
the Saints lose
Marcus Davenport left toes are no joke
do you know I'm genuinely surprised they
call it turf toe sometimes that is the
worst name for whatever the injury that
really is the worst thing I'm surprised
it doesn't happen every game at least a
half a dozen times it's lawful you know
denied if your feet get hurt Deon who
sat in here Monday Deion Sanders didn't
have any injury Deion Sanders career
came to an end is stellar to sport
playing career came to an because of a
toe injury what do you say about it you
don't have to say anything all he's
gonna do is take a shoe off and we'll
look at it you will say I cannot unsee
that why is this stuff bent and why get
that one toe goes over another and I
don't want to get too deep into it but I
don't even I I was not here I was over
Saskatchewan and he was doing a show he
was I bet you he wasn't he was wearing
some soft shoe right soft shoe and he's
you know kind of limping to this day boy
he is saying he took his shoes off for
the desk which normally I would find a
heinous act of it's okay Wendy on
Deficit is because number one I know
he's a shower and individual and number
two I understand it's an injury plus
he's one of the 10 greatest athletes of
our generation so you get a coupon by
the way you could say father you could
say top five unit to top five I
Rinke dion bow top five lost thirty
years
yes sure dion bow right
who will Chamberlain I mean if you're
saying last thirty years last that so
we're talking about nineteen ninety SAT
on charter right would you throw Jordan
in there or no you wouldn't throw Jordan
I think you have to I mean just in terms
of family quickness athleticism do you
put a track athlete in there do you
Karl Louis in there bolts Usain Bolt
Carlos I think Karl's a better athlete
on this list than Usain Bolt okay
athletically long jump four hundred two
hundred one hundred and the fifth is
tricky Fernando Valenzuela wait a minute
is this thing on our total cologne is
America's Sweetheart yes okay one of the
big movers in the NFL trade deadline
yesterday the foot off the Eagles went
out and grabbed Golden Tate to add to
the whole event that great move Howie
Roseman said why he's making that move
you're always trying to get the best
price there's no doubt about it but
we're not trying to win the trades we're
trying to get really good players and
the message to our fans to our players
to our coaches to everyone in this
organization is our foots always gonna
be on the gas and we're always trying to
win we're always gonna try to put our
best foot forward and what we can do now
is try to do that for this season and
this moment and nothing we're gonna do
and that's our responsibility love it
but on the gas he went to he went to
Notre Dame yes real name is golden a
golden dome are named Golden Tate you
know it's interesting
his if I'm not wrong if I'm not mistaken
you know in the old days if your father
was a cobbler if your father was doing
shoes for horses you largely would yes I
think his father was his height the high
school football coach and what what
spawns you also determines what you are
not in all cases but I love when that is
the case now he is I mean how are you
not imprinted by that correct I don't
know what Howie rosemond's dad did but I
made moves I made moves maybe he's an
agent I don't know my other favorite a
law ilk along that ilk is
when people's names reflect their job
Mike quick mean of course by the way I
saw him hop of the heap he's a
broadcaster for the Eagles I saw him in
London Mike write your greatest thing
ever
well but ker Harrison quietly but
carries the butt kicker Dick Butkus yeah
I mean of course that's his name of
course the greatest names of all time as
we've mentioned this weekend
Packers Patriots Tom Brady Aaron Rodgers
the show down everyone wants to see Mike
McCarthy was asked about that today well
and I think this is clearly going to be
right there or maybe the best ever I
mean the Montana John Elway it was
something I was interrogating around 93
94 and you know I just caught you over
the Monday night game up there where
well you know we had with that scored
and then jump came to Kansas City and
John took us right John I always took
them right back and scored and Joe took
the you know Chiefs right back down and
scored there at the last place so you
know Miami a little bit of the game we
played against San Francisco so but yeah
I think I think you know the irony of it
is they don't play against each other
why'd you choose that sound byte for
your news I just want to just watch just
going through the the list of and it
just further illustrates what Aaron
Rodgers is dealing with on a weekly
basis that is able to be so great all
the time when this is the man in his ear
calling plays for Packers fans Super
Bowl years ago you coached him to so I
don't think it was because of anything
Mike McCarthy did when you have number
12 out there and Greg Jennings is coming
in Mike McCarthy turn into the the David
Blatt of the Green Bay Packers when did
that happen
why don't you become a guy who just
rolls the ball out and it just it's
that's a good question but a Packers
fans want to call us and tell us please
also because look I don't know a Packers
fan who likes Mike McCarty right right
now I know and by the way I was about to
do until he just started rambling on I
was going to do a what was he really
thinking go ahead hit me with what was
it there's a new segment we do every now
and then
what were they really thinking well
here's what I was really thinking when
you asked me about Aaron Rodgers I want
to equate him with some of the Great's
of all time certainly the guy in terms
of Tom Brady because I think he kinda
hates my guts right now that's what he's
really thinking yeah that's the
narrative right that they can't stand
each other and they're winning in spite
of each other and that Aaron Rodgers if
he played a headline that I saw right
now is uh recently that Bella check with
how he'd throw for 7,000 yards inside
Daniels and Belichick
on ESPN right now it's a what-if of what
if Rodgers played with one of my bucket
list stadiums is and you've been there
so the question is Lambeau unbelievable
what is when you say people always do
that what's so special about because
it's in it's in well first of all that
you know who's played there before okay
so you know that that's hallowed turf
and then Buzzy's Thurston Locke it's
it's similar to let's say Wrigley and
the fact that it's old and the fact that
you're driving there is a Kmart there's
a gas station there's a stadium Oh
in the same way of Wrigley you know
there's the house there's a house
there's a stadium right it's
unbelievable how many people seventy
seventy thousand gets bless they've
expanded over the years yeah they have
um believe that's that's one of my
bucket it's a it's a bowl stadium right
it just goes up and there's nothing here
there's nothing like that when we've
been there watching Mariucci try Lambeau
leap that's high that is a high five you
tried it I did did you met you got the
ups though oh my god no it was terrible
I have no ups you have no hard downs all
that speed you generate I have no ups Oh
speed all that velocity yeah the
physical you can't convert that into a
vertical leap I know what the physics or
against me really yeah couple
quarterback news Jags are signing go
Andrew Jones as an insurance policy
there's some concern about Blake bortles
health following the one yeah Matt
Barkley one your deal to the bills
because Derek Anderson has a concussion
I'm not sure he's available
Nathan Peterman gonna start this way
Zoro can you tell me the record for an
NFL team there's enough to be for this
show if you can get it by the end of
this show great if not then friend of
this week and I'll let John C McKinley
as well no later on the record for
different number of
quarterbacks to throw a pick six in a
season one team the Josh Allen throw
pick six I think he's had so if that's
the case then Peterman Josh Allen Derick
Anderson just did it Berkeley eventually
maybe the kid on the Jets did it his
first pass and Arnold did I know then he
beat the lines beat the line a weird
story that Jimmy Butler thing just keeps
getting weirder shams is saying that
Butler is taking the next step in a
six-week long process aimed at getting
him out of Minnesota he's gonna sit
tonight against Utah and could lead to
an extended absence what a 6-1 I mean
six weeks is he really mapped it out I
think he has like a six week point what
I'm sitting now yeah week - I'm gonna
absolutely verbally destroy karl-anthony
towns in practice week three I'm gonna
go on the jump in Los Angeles and I'm
gonna throw everyone under the bus week
four I'll just take off week five I'm
gonna score 50 and then week six Aldo
it's a hell of a self-assessment okay
quick baseball David Price exercises
player option of course he's got 127
million left and Clayton Kershaw has
until midnight tonight decided in his
two years 65 million dollar extension
with the dog by the way I go
trick-or-treating in his neighborhood
with the kids well maybe you should I'm
gonna I'm gonna ask I want only fun size
candy and let me know I'll break the
news on some peanut butter cups break
the news to mr. incredible I'll show up
it's great to see you John C McKinley
tremendous to you I love this come back
any time even when you're not promoting
any 1% I'd love to
I'd love to happen I don't just say that
willy-nilly I mean why wouldn't we a
great question
check out IFC's season three of stand
against evil tonight at 10:00 p.m. and
then every single Wednesday thereafter
eight new episodes back-to-back every
Wednesday at 10:00 p.m. and 10:30 p.m.
Eastern Time follow him on Twitter I do
at John see McGinley the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience